and then we got a quick squeak of the
week clip because this is coming from
jake paul
um who wants to fight conor mcgregor and
call that his wife it'd be nice to see
jake paul get his [ __ ] head peeled
it'd be nice to just see him get his
head knocked off by conor mcgregor
because i understand
you know what you got to do and he's
very rich and famous and the kids got
success beyond success i mean that's his
crib
you know timmy d knows him i'm sure he's
a great guy but i mean you know when
when you do stuff like this it just
makes the people be like okay i hope
conor comes out knocks your head off
even if he is a nice guy
yeah and um also
also um uh yeah it's um
you know he knocked out nate robinson
who's like a retired basketball player
who's not a real boxer
right so yeah it would to you know i
understand
that america entertainment's become a
little bit of a freak show
so this would be nice it would be a nice
thing to just kind of put an end to it
right like
yes conor mcgregor like really hurt him
because
that's what would happen in that is like
conor mcgregor would really hurt him you
think he might do it conor mcgregor is
it possible
you think no no i mean it's like what
what's he what you got to gain out of it
i mean
there's money there but there's money
there if he fights a real person it kind
of degrades the sport a little bit
i mean you know but the good thing about
dana white and ufc is like all the guys
that have wanted to do it like boxers
dana white's going like yeah come on try
it out
because the truth is mma fighters are
the real fighters they're the guys
like uh yeah weather is a great boxer in
boxing's a great sport but at the end of
the day
fights always you always get your hands
on somebody and that's why
the greatest fighters are always
wrestlers i mean look at khabib he's
maybe the greatest of all time
you know brazilian jiu jitsu and
wrestling is always going to win out
so conor mcgregor is gonna get his
[ __ ] paws on this kid and he's gonna
he's gonna what would he say he's gonna
pound his head off the pavement you know
off the ground
but this would be he's doing
specifically a boxing match he wants to
do with conor mcgregor not ufc
oh well then yeah yeah i mean you know
conor mcgregor uh probably did the best
against the best boxer
ever i mean conor mcgregor he's a
celebrity make no mistake but the kid
can fight
and when he lost to khabib he was on a
two-year hiatus and he was
drinking yeah so uh any anyone around
so i mean conor mcgregor can fight for
real like
there's no question he's legit let's
listen to this jake paul clip
i mean yeah let's listen to it i mean
it's on his youtube
here we go what the [ __ ] is up you irish
[ __ ] good morning conor mcgregor i know
you're probably beating up old dudes in
a bar right now or maybe you're jacking
off because you're sick of [ __ ] your
wife i mean she's a four connor you
could do a lot better but happy monday
my team sent you a 50 million offer this
morning 50 million dollars cash
proof of funds the biggest fight offer
you've ever been offered but you're
scared to fight me conor
you're duck me because you don't want to
lose to a [ __ ] youtuber you're all in
one as a boxer
i'm 2-0 as a boxer i just came off the
eighth biggest
pay-per-view event in history but you
want to fight dustin prober
who has less followers on instagram than
my [ __ ] dog
that's a fact and dana white you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you ugly
[ __ ] bald [ __ ] you said there's zero
percent chance of this fight happening
but there's zero percent chance of you
getting some [ __ ] [ __ ]
conor you're scared dana you're scared
sign the [ __ ] contract you idiots
jesus [ __ ] christ irish [ __ ]
no he wants to fight him i guess mma he
wants to fight him mma then right
well i kind of i'm i'm happy that dana
white
it's kind of like it's no comparison
really but it's kind of like
you know i understand money is money but
dana white and ufc don't need the money
it's kind of like when you know if a
comedy club
or theater would turn around say i'm not
just going to [ __ ] put somebody to do
stand-up
unless they actually do stand up you
know like that's what i think
dana white's doing he's like i'm not
just going to do this to do this like i
don't we don't need your money we don't
you're not a real fighter
yeah and i really didn't like the part
where he talked about his wife man you
know
but i know conor mcgregor has talked
[ __ ] about
other people's religions and stuff like
that so conor mcgregor has crossed the
line a little bit as well
but it's just that's just stuff to piss
people off there's no basis in that
wrong it's just it comes off wrong it
just comes off like
dude don't talk about the guy's wife i
mean i mean how desk i mean what have we
become man like what have we become like
that's just below the belt i mean you
know i guess it's entertainment but you
know
i guess nobody gives a [ __ ] what we have
to say because we don't we're not
fighting nate robinson
bubba's here we go by the way we got an
xbox
series x for all our friends and all our
listeners xbox series x you can win
a free xbox series x all you got to do
is subscribe to both of our history
hyenas youtube channels the regular page
and the clips page
and share a favorite episode or clip
with a friend
and post screenshots of these two things
to your twitter
or instagram and use the hashtag h
giveaway
hashtag h giveaway january 20th we will
announce the winner the day of biden's
inauguration we're going to announce the
winner
uh as we enter into a communist regime
we're gonna give you a free xbox of
course tag the history hyenas in that
so we all see it hashtag hh giveaway do
those two things get a chance to win an
xbox
xbox series x yeah i mean who loves you
more than us
uh so make sure you use that hashtag and
binky and venatia will be perusing and
we will pick a winner and that's just
what's going to happen
with us in the morning
in the morning
in the morning